Diving this tomb is so high risk
that we're sending an underwater camera drone in first
to see if it's even possible.
You guys ready?
Yeah, we're ready. Let's go down.
I'mma see how far I can get it down.
Maybe I can get it right to the entrance.
Copy. Here we go, I've got video feed.
Well, King Nastasen, we come with good intentions
to tell your story.
Please take care of us.
Alright.
I'm swimming now.
I'll try to get you right to the entrance.
Okay.
He's dragging it down now.
Mm-hmm.
Okay! It's pretty far down there.
Yeah?
Oh, this is gnarly.
I can't see anything.
Okay, I'm gonna get you right to the entrance
and let go, okay?
Okay, yeah.
Line it up straight.
Did you get there?
Yeah. I think I'm in.
Let's see how it looks on the camera.
Alright. Moving forwards.
This is such a challenging environment
to navigate through.
You can barely see anything and it just glimmers.
Here we go, here we go. It's opening up a little bit.
So, that's a corner of one of the chambers.
Alright. Real subtle,
light movements now.
Look right there.
Oh, what is that?
I think that's the top of the door
going into the third chamber.
So, this is where the king would've been buried.
We are in the burial chamber.
Alright, look there.
That's the left side of the slab.
Wow.
And this is either
the corner of the top of a platform
on which the king would've been buried,
or it's the top of some sort of casing for the king.
Ah, you barely make it out though,
through the murk.
Just a glimpse, right?
It's good news.
If we know we're in the third chamber,
then we know that each of the entranceways
to each chamber is clear.
You know it's safe.
Yeah.
So, I think we're gonna have to get
in there somehow.
This gives us good information and lets us know we can
at least navigate in and out.
Space inside this fragile tomb
is extremely tight.
Prioritizing the protection of the tomb,
there's only room for Pearce Paul and his support diver.
If you can find any clues that can tell us anything about
who he is or where he came from,
that's what we're looking for.
We'll go in. We'll see what we can find
and bring out what we got.
As the scanning team continue
their 3D modeling of the site,
we get set to search the flooded tomb.
Alright, guys. Good luck.
They must be entering the third chamber now.
Hoping this is where we find what we're looking for.
What is that in his hand right there?
Okay, he's back at the surface.
What?!
Oh, that was a face.